since we're going to be using
powerpoints today it's awkward to stand
up but it also seems weird to be sitting
behind this desk
so
i'm going to do what in japan would be
extremely uncouth but in california you
can kind of get it with it and have dan
like come and sit on the front of this
desk so we sort of got a bar stool kind
of thing going on with the front of the
desk
and see if that doesn't um
sort of
soften up the fields a little bit give
it kind of a more of a casual fireside
chat sort of feel
okay so now i'm feeling really guilty
because my wife is japanese and you
should be feeling guilty too
um so
i presented once or twice here in the
past and talked about how the japanese
entrepreneurship ecosystem is evolving
and
in talking about sunbridge here i'd
mentioned that we had two goals at the
beginning of the company
one was to prove that there was enough
entrepreneursh entrepreneurial activity
in japan
and enough great businesses being formed
that it was possible to produce
world-class silicon valley style returns
running a vc fund there that there's
enough great companies being formed that
you can do good investing in in tokyo
the second
goal that we set with starting sunbridge
in 2000 was that we wanted to be
backing startups that whose business
didn't stop in japan who built companies
that
could compete effectively with their
peers in silicon valley and eventually
be the next generation of emergent
japanese global leaders
and
as the first we we've
had to work with a lot of great
companies in japan have had good
investment returns but until about uh
two or three years ago
almost no new startups being formed in
japan were growing beyond japan's
borders the market's big enough there
that you can get quite big without
taking on that more challenging issue of
going overseas
um we've had we had a couple of
companies over the years that had
the potential to go global but didn't
execute on it for various reasons in one
case because they were under pressure to
go public very quickly and
went public when they were still too
small and couldn't grow
so for for 12 years i've been
looking for
working with startups in japan hoping
that at some point one or two of them
become really credible global players so
that's all kind of the setup
for how i got to know dan and his
co-founder
kato-san tatsuya kato-san when they
started midokura a couple of years ago
when they presented to me the
software-defined networking space and
and why
networking also would be virtualized
just as cpus and storage had been
i didn't get it i i'm i
i'm not going to attempt to explain this
sdn space here that's what we've got
down for
but for me
when they first approached me about
possibly making an angel investment in
the company shortly after it was formed
the thing that really captured my
imagination about this company compared
to anything else i'd seen in tokyo in 12
years was the ceo at the time was
japanese had a background in both
technology and investing
uh dan uh
i'll have you i'll have you introduce
yourself in a moment but
he's obviously not
japanese i'll leave it at that and let
him tell you a little more about himself
later
another co-founder in the team had dan
worked with amazon.com had worked with
google here in the united states and
the team
of i think seven or eight people at the
time were all
bilingual whether they were foreigners
who were
native fluency in japanese
or japanese with native fluency i'd
never met a team like this
and part of
kato-san who at the time the company was
founded was working as the ceo part of
his pitch to me was we're trying to
build a global company and silicon
valley companies google but they're all
indians at the start they're all chinese
they're all americans and they sell to
companies in silicon valley for their
school years they don't really start as
global companies they start as silicon
valley companies eventually grow global
and we're starting as a global company
so for me
i had i i did not get
the opportunity for about six months
with the company what i got was here's
here's a team that's unlike any other
i've run into in tokyo
this team
really may have the potential assuming
assuming that they are right about the
technology opportunity they're pursuing
this is a team that could potentially go
global and so for the last two years
we've been
working together
uh
for and dan's been really helped me
realize one of my dreams of japanese
startups going global and so for me it's
it's a special privilege today to be
able to have have him here at this forum
in stanford
uh and
i'll share
one more bit of news with you before
turning time to dan to kind of introduce
himself
but he the reason he's here and i will
do this today
instead of the gentleman ben that runs
the operations for them in the u.s is
that always on
picked midokura as one of their 100
world-leading on-demand players and had
him come out to receive
recognition as one of the 100 most
interesting cloud companies yesterday so
so um
i thought that that getting him to come
here to stanford was going to be kind of
a special
opportunity to get him in front of a
crowd in silicon valley he he was in
front of an even
with all due respect more interesting
cloud crowd
last night so that that's kind of the
setup and how
for me
at the outset uh the main thing that was
really interesting about mediocre is a
team in tokyo composed of bilingual
people from
around the world
pursuing a very very hardcore
technology
that
as i got to understand it
if if it becomes as big as it could be
is you know on the order of an industry
creating
along the lines like we talked about and
it occurred to me that maybe the easiest
way for me to understand it was
that mediocre companies like it are
trying to become
to cisco what microsoft was to ibm
it is two to the to the proprietary
expensive
uh
networking gear companies the software
platform that makes it possible for
a commodity off-the-shelf software to do
everything that that they so so
midokura and the companies like them
potentially
uh
to to the level to the extent that i
understand the opportunity uh are maybe
like
maybe to cisco juniper and others what
microsoft was to ibm in the day so
dan
came out to introduce yourself and
kind of set the stage to talk a little
bit about
software to define that receive see if
you can do a better job explaining to
them than you and katelyn did to me in
that meeting of
helping them understand the
power and potential and then the
necessity for software-defined
networking
uh so first of all thank you very much
for having me here today i'm i'm quite
honored to have this opportunity i'm
really not used to speaking in front of
uh
i guess you're all business students or
technology business students and
frankly speaking i'm not sure if i can
teach you anything at all but uh maybe
despite that you can you can learn
something from my experiences
so i'm uh originally i'm a computer
scientist i graduated from cornell
actually and uh
i worked in a variety of startups
some in
networking not exactly like the cisco
type you know more like application
level i worked in infrastructure at
amazon i worked in a financial services
in new york
and about three and a half years ago
i actually had this idea of
going to japan and starting a cloud
computing business
and actually despite everything that
that alan said i'm going to totally like
dash your
your presentation actually sure
when i met kato-san and uh we decided to
start this business our focus was
actually very local you know initially
yeah it was actually on on doing a
service business
locally in japan
and so
we built the company and got one of
kato-san's acquaintances the ceo of a
data center company in tokyo they had
like lots of the physical assets
networking but none of the software
expertise let's say so they actually put
money into our company fairly early on
to help them to build a
cloud service infrastructure as a
service kind of similar to amazon aws in
in the types of functionality
and so that's what we started doing in
the middle of 2010
and while we were doing that
we
decided we were building as much as we
were reusing as much as we could out of
open source and
but there were a few things that we
couldn't uh find off the shelf or we
couldn't really easily integrate
and one of them was
the virtualized networking services
now this is before anybody was talking
about sdn and such and
frankly i don't really like that term
because it's a bit non-descriptive it's
just a bit broad
so what our company provides is virtual
networking services for the
infrastructure as a service cloud so you
have virtualized compute virtualized
storage and then
various network services like
you know switching routing firewall load
balancing etc that need to be available
in that kind of multi-tenant environment
we build that that software layer
so fast forward a little bit uh our
initial business idea did not actually
work out and so we decided to uh focus
on the software stack instead and so
anybody heard of a silicon valley
company that ended up doing something
different than they thought they were
going to do at the outset right
same same scenario plays out uh just as
often in japan well
i don't even know anything about that i
can only speak about our our specific
situation but yeah um so we decided to
change the software and uh i think that
that shift was fairly successful
and uh since then the whole
infrastructure space actually has taken
off there's a lot more interest in it
because
cloud computing is becoming much bigger
private clouds are becoming all hot the
openstack project which some of you may
be familiar with started in 2010 that's
an open source project uh started by
rackspace to
provide like the core of uh you know
what it takes to build a
virtualized compute storage networking
environment like amazon aws either on
premises or as a public cloud so we
joined that as well and so our our
product works with openstack and with
other
open cloud management platforms
so what are what are a couple of the key
technical issues or technical problems
in
current approaches to data center
network management
that
you and companies like you address and
then what are some of some of the
business justification or the business
issues that that make people consider
looking at looking at something like you
right so i mean
just from the user's perspective what is
the user trying to get out of this
they're trying to get virtualized
excuse me services compute services in
the form of virtual machines virtualized
storage services like virtual disks and
such and then the networking services
that interconnect all these things
and
traditional networking hardware is not
designed really for this kind of
multi-tenant environment i mean there
are some primitives in there like
vlans if you you know virtual lands for
isolation ethernet those are just not
appropriate as primitives to
in this kind of environment they don't
scale they're not fault tolerant
um
there's a variety of reasons why that's
not the right way to build
the
the the networking services in a very
dynamic environment like uh this type of
cloud computing it's not just it's not
just the ethernet it's also the routing
and the load balancing they're not
they're not scalable they're not fault
tolerant
so all these things kind of have to be
rebuilt frankly speaking from scratch in
that kind of environment
um yes it's possible to take a bunch of
traditional devices and cobble them
together but it's probably not going to
work very well when you try to scale it
out or to manage it
so
when you initially started the company
the data center
firm gave you some money to build a
system for them initially that was kind
of your seed capital
how did how did you go about raising the
money if in my in my case i know it was
a global team was what attracted me but
but when did you kind of shift to
being more abort abroad software play
and how easy or difficult
was it for you to get the initial
capital to
to shift from being a service provider
to a software creator well i think yeah
raising capital was hard it was it was
very hard and i think that's actually
one of the as you probably know very
well it's one of the really hardest
things about doing uh this type of
high risk high reward business in japan
because most of the local vc firms are
not at risk
they don't have such a high appetite for
risk so our initial couple of million
dollars of capital were from strategic
investors
including bit isle the data center
company and ntt
who uh you know they they have a broad
interest in networking and network
virtualization
um
and then after that
kmart series a which was relatively uh
recent it was just a couple of months
ago so it was actually quite a long span
between when we got our seed capital and
when we raised our series a
uh and i think a couple of things
contributed to
successfully raising series a was that
we had actually built the product and we
actually actually got in traction which
was definitely not the case you know
back when we got the
the
initial money and we grew the company
very slowly um
when you invested in us i think it was
like in 2011 late 2011. and it was like
we had seven people now we have 27
people yeah uh but that's
relatively slow by silicon valley uh
growth standards you know i think
i think in our case it was actually fine
because the market
wasn't there before and now it's kind of
coming into reality so if we had grown
uh faster earlier we would have burned
money a bit unnecessarily i think
but like i said we did grow very slowly
and and part of it was because we didn't
have the cash and part of it was because
it was really difficult to hire the
right people at that time
um
that's actually gotten a lot easier so
that's that's
an interesting aspect of doing the
business as we became more well-known
i'm sure that
um
along the way i i kind of pushed you
yeah to
open a center in silicon valley try and
raise money here because i i believed
that you would not be able to get five
or ten million dollars in capital in
japan you had to do it here could you
talk a little bit about
your experience and whether you think
your experience trying to raise money in
the valley was different than silicon
valley startups of a similar size and
stage or
how how did that process
work
and
why do you think in the end
uh
you weren't able to raise money in the
valley and then yet you were able to
raise a surprisingly large amount back
in japan so talk a little bit about you
know where you were as a company
and
whether in retrospect
did it actually was there anything
useful that you gained out of trying to
raise money here uh right and is there
do you have a sense that there's a
chance that you would ever be able to
raise money here as a japanese company
or
right right that's a that's a great
question um
yeah to be perfectly honest i don't
think we ever really tried very hard to
raise the money here okay we i know you
pushed us and we did open an office in
uh in san francisco and we have but we
have a team in the over here
uh at this point because realistically
for a variety of reasons not not just
money but we have to be plugged into the
ecosystem of partner companies and
potential customers in in the area here
um but i would say yeah we never really
tried to raise money here that hard
and
but going through the process going
through the road show that we did
together it was very useful because the
the vcs here were much more critical you
know i think of a variety of things of
the product of the market
and of the team lots of things
so that that did help i think to sharpen
our
certainly our presentation skills uh and
to a certain extent our focus uh of the
product in the market
um and that was i think when was that
there was like a year and a year ago a
year ago a year ago
and so in the end uh we we kind of gave
up on it basically
we weren't we're on going that way and
at the at the same time we're pursuing
uh
capital from our from our japanese
investors
and uh that ended up coming through but
i think it was actually interesting
because
working to raise money in the valley was
was kind of what pushed them over the
over the edge as well to invest because
there was interest from the silicon
valley
uh capital
enough
that was that it would influence them
um my feeling was that they needed to
have some kind of external validation
they needed to have somebody tell them
like this is okay you know and then they
were ready to to take the risk
let's shift a little bit talk about kind
of the organization you've you've got an
interesting mixture
of people from different countries in
tokyo you've got
as a just 27 person company you've got
three locations internationally
um what are you finding
about how easy or hard it is to
recruit
the quality of talent that you've been
able to recruit in tokyo versus
say the people you're working with at
amazon or people you've worked with in
the united states what's your sense
of the talent
the pool uh and what are some things
that you watch for as a founder and ceo
when when you're hiring rooting and kind
of building your team so
to hire uh our team in in tokyo um
first of all it's there are 35 million
people in the metro area there's tons of
talent i mean around most of it though
is locked up in very large corporations
you know and uh they don't want to come
out you know or they don't know that
they can
you know in terms of those japanese
engineers and i think a lot of people
would have a hard time because of the
language issues as well
but you know i don't want to
broadly generalize there but for us for
for our company we've built an excellent
team i think in in tokyo
absolutely rivaling any kind of a local
company here in the valley
that said
some of the domain expertise isn't quite
there you know at least not accessible
to us for instance we
we don't have anybody well we have one
guy who worked at cisco who's actually
in in tokyo
um
but not you know here we could get like
you know 50 guys from cisco to up and
quit and come join us
so it's a little harder to access the
talent so we had to use like headhunters
and recruiters a lot more than we would
have here uh our personal networks have
you been able to pull talent from some
of the
big established companies
you know like from nec and from any ntt
we did
um
and some from from smaller companies
i think the team is is good it's good
enough like like i said there is enough
of a human capital base there
more than enough you know to to build
your team whatever you're trying to do
and and surprisingly large numbers of
foreigners as well
um
americans europeans etc
so all those questions are kind of there
may be some other factors to consider
all kind of leading up to
the big question that i always like to
talk about when i have a chance here at
stanford is
uh if you're doing it all over again
do you think you'd have a better shot
at ultimately being successful
starting from day one in the valley
where you're surrounded by other
competitors
or
do you do you think you would
deliberately choose to start it in tokyo
again or maybe your home country or
somewhere in europe so what's your sense
uh of how easy the pros and cons of
trying to do a startup outside the
valley versus in the valley
from what you're experiencing i think
it's i think it really is a
double-edged sword you know being in the
valley or not being valid
first of all i did not have any strong
personal network in the valley uh when
starting this company okay so i would
have had to live here for years you know
in order to build that up and come here
so in your case there was a
largely different by you know personal
networking so it's the same for me with
sunbridge after 10 years doing oracle in
japan to start doing startup investing
didn't make a lot of sense for me to do
it here because even though it was
oracle it was
in tokyo so my name is paradoxically i
actually had a better network to
do investors in tokyo than here so it's
that's just my personal weirdness you
know a weird situation in that sense but
uh what's your sense if you were if you
were to generalize though
um
i think it's really you know like all
the mechanics of you know starting a
company and getting things together it's
all very easy over there very simple
actually getting getting visas for for
foreign workers trivial compared to the
united states
really i mean it's like it's amazing
that said there are lots of other
barriers you know to getting people to
actually go over there to
to work there it's the
you know the hidden barriers right like
a language and some sort of aversion to
to be i mean i think it's a great place
more people should go there
start companies and live there and try
it out but
um
that doesn't really happen in reality
not right now
um i think people are you know that our
employees they're they're very loyal
there's a lot less jumping around so i
don't think you have to worry about
people going to your competitors and
things like that if that if that is a
concern
but uh
you know do you do you have any
competitors locally in japan they're
actually local actually we do yeah
there's one it's it's never told me
about another board meetings really yes
i did yes i did
it's a company called stratosphere okay
it's a the joint venture between iij and
uh infusion okay yeah yeah yeah
they're actually very good i think
technically
yeah they're actually very good
technically i think but they haven't
they're they've extremely um locally
focused marketing
okay how many how many people would you
broadly say are competitors that
originate here in the valley maybe
boston so yeah like
three or four basically okay so here in
the valley so you're in our space so
having having one other competitor in
tokyo you're like two out of five or six
maybe globally yeah yeah interesting but
i would say like in the in the market
that we're targeting which is let's say
uh private clouds being built on
openstack or cloud stack this this type
of system um
you know i don't want to like pat
ourselves on the back but i think we're
we're a player you know we're one of the
top three players in in that space well
always on that i think so if they know
if they know something you know
um
yeah i think i think we are and i think
it's uh
kind of amazing you know that we were
able to build that uh without without
having been here uh the whole time so
ultimately i was always very worried you
know i started off as the cto my
japanese partner was the ceo
we decided to change roles but my
concern was always that
uh i always had this kind of inferiority
complex and concerned that we're lacking
the right talent but you know
you know we're we're making all kinds of
mistakes etc
and uh
well where we've gotten to right now i
think we've gotten to a pretty good
pretty reasonable place you know for for
our stage
and frankly speaking we spent far less
money far less money than than our
competitors so far
about about five five and a half million
dollars
to get to to get to this point
yeah well i remember you in in
reviewing the
feedback from the silicon vases you
mentioned that several of them had said
they were astonished at how much
software being able to build with the
small amount of capital that you would
have to use which
yeah because we don't have to pay
ourselves you know two hundred thousand
dollars a year a year
yeah to to work there yeah yeah
um
so
where where in terms of commercial
rollout or user adoption do you think
this shift to
more dynamically definable
virtual
networking where you had to use to pull
pull and plug wires you described you
mentioned i mean to really do
fundamental load balancing
to
where amazon
today and their internal systems is like
allowing you to dynamically move data
around from one physical location to a
completely different physical location
so where are we in terms of
adoption of the technology beyond just
the amazons and googles that build it
in-house
and is this something that ever moves
beyond
a few
data center service providers to being
kind of
take us take a stab at the is this
category really potentially a microsoft
to cisco sort of play or is it is it
in terms of the market there's a lot of
fascinating stuff going on right now you
know so basically yes this category is
going to be huge and who's going to be
able to win it you know is
definitely an open question not in terms
of us versus one of our other startup
competitors
but in terms of
the juggernauts uh
vmware uh microsoft and amazon uh versus
kind of everybody else you know in that
sense so uh right now the movement
basically seems to be
a lot of i don't know if you you may be
familiar with this but over the since
amazon started there's business there's
been this movement in the enterprise
shadow i.t you know people people are
calling it where basically internal id
departments are so incompetent you know
that the users actually just go straight
straight to amazon and use their compute
and whatnot their services and so at
some point the corporations they get
they get mad they want to pull that
stuff back in the it departments want to
change or they're forced to change and
so now they have to adopt these agile
practices and
provide the same kind of services
practically speaking in fact they have
to provide the exact same service you
know as amazon because the users are
used to that now
uh so that's driving the need for the
type of private cloud software that
openstack cloud stack and then other
stacks like this
are offering you know that type of
functionality and
other associated
services like the networking services
storage services and
such
so yes it's definitely a very real
market it's going to happen
um that said uh vmware who is kind of
king of virtualization in the enterprise
but not so much cloud you know it's it's
there's a difference there
uh they're uh they've got a strategy and
it's it's very interesting you know
their strategy is they're going to build
their own public cloud
and then and then make this kind of
experience of using the internal
computer resources and the ones in in in
their cloud
be seamless that's their pitch
it's very recent actually just i think
they just uh announced that yesterday
um
so
at the same time they don't know
anything about operating a service you
know relatively speaking right like
they're they provide software so who
knows about operating services it's
amazon
and microsoft you know they're quite
quite big and quite competent and to a
certain extent uh rackspace and other
you know second tier cloud providers
from rackspaces here but uh so
i think that microsoft could execute a
similar strategy you know as vmware is
you know with this with this hybrid
model
amazon they don't they don't
they're very good at service not so much
a product you know
shipping a product so we'll see we'll
see how that goes
and then there is the entire uh
ecosystem of the open players
like their openstack movement which is
not so much a product but it is like an
alternative architecture and technology
which is actually being pushed by
rackspace i think that actually has a
big chance to be a contender
because
all the world's
largest uh telco companies they're
looking desperately for new sources of
revenue so one of the things they want
to get into is providing compute
services to complement all their network
services
and so it seems like they're being
pushed in the direction of going with
openstack
and banding together to sort of provide
a an alternative to all this so a lot of
dynamic stuff going on in the market
it's very interesting
so
there's a question we've talked about a
little bit internally and
this you're just mentioning openstack
now reminded me of a conversation that
went on at tycon
last friday i think was the session
uh and there was a lot of debate about
whether
hadoop needed to remain a pure open
source non-commercial environment in
order to keep innovating and growing or
whether intel and other companies who
are adding you know support and and
proprietary things around that
environment if that
creating a proprietary environment for
the cloud computing infrastructure was
the way the industry so you kind of had
the intel and ibm on one side saying
well you've got to have some
professional services and more
structure around it and the hacker
community on the other side saying well
if if we go down that path we'll kill it
just like we did at t and bsd unix back
in the 90s and and ended up with a lot
of conflicting things so any any read on
how
the the virtual networking open source
open stack versus commercial product is
going to be coexistence you think it's
likely to shift orient toward
one direction or the other well my view
and from my somewhat limited experience
i think that in order for the majority
of customers and companies to consume
this stuff it does have to be
productized and that means that it has
to have a lot of services around it uh
initially
it has to have support it cannot be
like the current state of openstack
which is you know toss it over the wall
you know pick it up and then good luck
for you there are very few organizations
that can actually handle that uh
internally like
count them on your fingers you know
so um
now red hat you know they've gotten into
the openstack uh game they're gonna
they're actually they've quickly
actually become the largest contributor
to the open source project
and we're working with them as well
and they're gonna provide an actual
product which hopefully is gonna be very
good and well supported
that's gonna be much more consumable for
the vast majority of enterprises just
like linux i mean who could use linux
before before red hat uh
provided it you know as a product
very few organizations could do that by
themselves even when i was at amazon
which was in
2004 to 2007 they were getting they were
using a red red hat enterprise linux
because they they needed the support at
some level
and that's amazon you know it's not
yeah so auto parts company you know
using building a cloud
um so i think that absolutely there's
there's still quite a long way to go
before this stuff is uh product worthy
uh which is why vmware has a huge head
start you know frankly speaking right
because they know how to make a product
and deliver it
best uh
it's all it's all very dynamic right now
very up in the air
i'm gonna pause for a second and see if
there's some questions from the arts
that might take conversation i'm
realizing now that the conversation has
been rather technical on the software
defined networking space
that
may
be interesting to people in the room but
maybe not the most so i'm going to take
a couple of violence questions and see
if we pull out sort of a
new direction that you might like to
take this particular chat so we'll start
with you and then you
um so with 27 people right now um what
is your vision and what is your
strategies on building a support team to
move it forward a support team that's a
that's a great question yeah because
we've been extremely engineering focused
until fairly recently so we just
actually just built a support team so um
we have some customers in japan which
need local support and we have to you
know have people there we also have to
do support in the us you know and so
it's we actually have to do for things
like marketing sales and support we have
to kind of build two separate teams
that's that's that's
it's a little hard to leverage the the
same resources you know the same people
to do both yeah uh we've been trying to
do that
somewhat unsuccessfully to be honest
they're they're right now just going
through that transition they've gone
from
from alpha development in a few
prototypes do they now have two
commercial
clients that's a little okay
it's a little further along than that
you know but they now they have
customers paying and having to support
having the support
yeah like i said we tried to do
everything in sort of the way that we
were used to working
didn't work out so well so far you know
so
yeah we we're yeah yeah
yeah that's right the stage where they
have to address that question yes so my
question is basically uh
how do you find clients so i know that
you're
you're competing it's based in japan
you're also
you're one of like i guess like a few
companies how exactly do you
find clients is it all just new
connections and is there a name and
already that they come
yeah
like that well you know the market is
very niche you know within the niche of
this cloud computing infrastructure
virtual networking i think our name is
well known well known enough so in the
u.s a lot of the clients we find through
the community of openstack
soon cloud stack and the red hat partner
network which we'll we're going to be uh
going to in in
i think in june
you've been coming to presenting the
events here even before you had the
office in san francisco haven't you a
little bit a little bit i mean we we
were i think the openstack community was
really important for getting our name
out there and and being
connected to the right types of
companies because they're ones that are
interested in building their own
infrastructure cloud infrastructure
they're also going to those those events
absolutely
in japan it's much easier because we're
in we're in tokyo
uh japan's a big country for the
customers everything is there you know
so through our network
we can access probably like at least
half the customers in the whole country
you know
um so quite different in that sense
yeah and that's all that's what we've
done so far you know the
us or broadly speaking the openstack
community which which does include some
companies from from europe and of course
asia too
uh and in japan
um i was wondering why barcelona over a
more high-tech country in europe like
ireland or germany that's a great
question
purely coincidental
one of my one of my uh old
friends and colleagues from amazon
after leaving amazon he moved there
was doing something completely different
and when he started working with our
company
uh he wanted to stay so
you know he had become such a critical
part of the team that i couldn't say no
but how's it working up what are you
finding to be the advantage of that
to versus you know it's it's pure
engineering right now over there and
we've done no business uh development or
sales in europe so uh so far all i can
say is that uh
very good engineers you know absolutely
which i think you know going back to
what we said earlier there are good
engineers all over the place you know
all over the world
it's just a question of finding them
that's the harder part uh here in the
valley they're very concentrated and
people are networking and talking to
each other whereas in other places they
tend to be more like trapped in the big
companies and
take so it takes more work to to find it
there is a question in the past
for the open source communities
especially in sdn space
do you see that as a barrier for new
startup coming up doing proprietary
product or kind of forcing the company
to do multi-service product oh that's
great question i mean yeah a lot of
people tell us all the time that
software is the stock the cost of
software is tending towards zero you
know and then we better switch to a
service company model and i frankly i
don't believe that i mean there's enough
value to be added and enough complexity
that will not be solved in the open
source community uh
for quite a while i mean there's a lot
of open source stuff out there
absolutely but
it's very not productized you know
if you're if you're a google yes you can
go and grab a bunch of stuff and put it
together or amazon
if you're uh
if you're not a high-tech company
no
you our exactly in our space
there is some
stuff there that can can be leveraged
you know to jump start um
i i have to be honest occasionally we
did we did receive pushback from certain
customers in the openstack community
saying i don't want to pay for this
you know i'm going to go do my own thing
but not many very few very few
okay
dan
i remember years ago when scott mcnealy
uh talked about october and of course
this was bdc
and um his claim were uh was very simple
it was nobody cares about
where your toast comes from just that
your toaster works yep okay
and um
what kind of barriers have you found
that are non-technical maybe more on the
emotional or psychological side with
your corporate clients to this or has it
been embraced and alan um the local vc
in the u.s um last i checked i think
it's roughly about 25 billion a year
invested and that number maybe is about
right
something like that what's the community
like in japan and do you have the
equivalent of like a sandhill road in
mental apartment there um where vcs are
kind of
physically located
um
yes you were talking about you know the
sort of emotional barriers to adoption
of this type of new technology
um
some of them might be a little obvious
you know for example when the internal
id departments are going to be changing
to automate everything you know people
are kind of worried about uh losing
control let's say especially in
networking teams
actually
i've seen this only in in some companies
like at amazon there's a separate team
for managing all the networking now if
all the infrastructure almost all the
infrastructure is virtualized that team
becomes smaller you know honestly or its
function has to change somewhat so yes
there is definitely resistance to
some of the new aspects of doing this uh
this networking i wouldn't call our
product a networking product per se
because we're not like we're not
replacing like the cisco switch it's a
piece of software you know that's part
of the
the virtualized computing environment in
in my view but it's not seen as such
always
seen as a bit of a threat
is this security any issues
any issues in security
well you know frankly speaking yes i
mean the enterprise has way different
security than
the amazon aws cloud right in that sense
uh but i think that
largely well to a certain to a great
extent the customers have gotten used to
that model of what they get on amazon
which is not much you know in the way of
security and therefore they have to work
around that or building into the
application rather than relying on uh
network appliances and such
so yeah we did we did get a lot of that
kind of pushback maybe
a year or two years ago which was can i
still use my firewall appliance from
such and such a vendor that's doing
something super specific uh but we're
not hearing a lot of that anymore so i
think that the mind shift has uh has
happened to some extent
yep
um
total
vc investment in japan was about two
billion dollars a year steady from the
early 90s until the
late 2000 and
until 2008
and in 2008 the japanese version of the
sox
law kicked in and caused plummeting in
the number of ipos that happened for a
couple of years and the lehman shock
happened and the economy which had been
growing for three four years
kind of
hit a roadblock and
in 2009 the total vc invested dropped
down to about a billion dollars and it's
just creeping up now back
it's back up to about 1.4 billion
dollars but
in japan there is one government
associated fund incj which also has
about a billion dollars to invest so
there's about a billion
billion and a quarter in total annual
investment by
uh the entire vc community and then
about another billion dollars
to be deployed by in government backed
government-run fund
and
in nature my view is that the u.s is
over-funded
and because it's over-funded that's part
of the reason why the large vc firms
don't invest in series a deals anymore
because the partners have come gotten
accused of this idea that they're each
responsible for managing 50 or 100
million dollars
and they can only do an effective job
working with five to six companies at a
time
so they have to have these big bite
sizes and a startup can't absorb
20 million dollars efficiently
unless you're in semiconductors or
capital intensities which the vcs don't
invest anymore so you've got this weird
dilemma going on of wanting to invest in
capital
light companies
but invest a lot of capital in them and
so the only way you can do that
productively is waiting until the
company's pretty well established and
you're investing in a major growth
expansion funding to hire a large
organization ahead of the opportunity so
the fact there is so much money
in
vc in the us i think is part of the
problem here and and part of why it's so
hard to get the series a funding
in american valley
uh and on the other hand uh
the japanese the professional vcs will
invest three five hundred thousand
dollars a pop in a relatively young
company but it's really hard to raise
five or ten million dollars as a private
company in japan so you have this this
inverse situation where where the
financial industry
uh
institutional vcs in japan will do seed
stage really early small a investing but
after you know two or three million
dollars in vc financing in japan
typically the next step is get to
operating profitability grow to 10 or 15
million dollars and take the company
public so there's not
there's a really weak follow-on
ecosystem
um as to the question about sand hill
road
uh tokyo itself as jan said is such a
huge proportion of the japanese economy
and within the yamate line basically you
can get anywhere within that line in a
30 minute train ride
uh so
central tokyo is where all the vcs are
and you there if there is a concert
there's a concentration of financial
uh institutional vcs around tokyo
station because that's where the banks
and insurance companies and
investment bankers all had their
headquarters so
there is sort of a cluster of vc offices
there
but
rather than startups going to the vcs in
tokyo the vcs tend to go to the startups
it's almost it's almost like the vcs are
selling to startups on take our money
not somebody else's
so there's there's there's a weird
there's a weird job uh
in bc in institutional vcs in japan for
new college grads
particularly the big firms like jafko
and jike who
opened the nikkei newspaper every
morning and if they read about some
company that they've never heard of they
try to be the first person in the
company to go out in content and say
when you need some money talk to us
and they they actually get rewarded
for
making the investments for finding
companies and making the investments
rather than on the back end and it's
because as an industry
the japanese financial vcs tend to think
of as a portfolio investing strategy to
spread a lot of money over a lot of
opportunities and
they they seem to have you know absorbed
most of them
the the
efficient market theory approach to
investing and they're applying that to
startups which
form a silicon foreign but that's the
way that's kind of the background in the
training that a lot of them bring to it
and then there are there are a handful
of
people approaching from from
an entrepreneurial or investor
background and recently there are a
number of angels and vcs that have been
started by people who were involved in
in creating internet companies around
2000 2001 but it's still a very small
portion of the industry
so i was very very
inverted
uh
i notice that your background is sort of
primarily technology
yeah um can you talk a little bit about
some of the challenges if any of that
you've had sort of moving from that hat
to the ceo had which is i generally can
because it's extremely recent you know
so it's fresh in my mind yeah uh
yeah i mean one of the things that i
have uh had an awakening about is just
the
what it means to have a product you know
and what the quality of the product has
to be you know to really be competitive
and sell it because before i was just
focused so much on technology itself uh
that
and actually to be frank the other thing
is
i have not worked on any kind of
shippable software product you know like
you know strong crap
internal technology a lot of services
and the way that when i was just talking
to my friend
about that you know when you operate a
service you do things very differently
than when you're actually uh shrink
wrapping it and shipping it to the
customer and having to support it as an
like externally
um
and the other thing is just thinking
more strategically delegating a lot more
i always tend to do everything you know
myself uh hands-on
thinking about
revaluing some of the other competencies
in the company besides engineering which
was like again where i was mostly
focusing on
so before i was thinking
marketing guy what a waste of money you
know
i know that sounds funny but you know
but in all seriousness i don't think
i've met any many engineers in my life
that uh
instinctively say otherwise yeah yeah
yeah
there's a lot there's a logical there's
a logical overlay you have to put over
your engineering thing to accept that
marketing might have some
no i i totally see it now i mean there's
there's so many of these you know
marketing and product management product
development and sales uh
hugely important you know and and i've
i've done a lot of refocusing you know
of the team um
last couple of months
yeah so
it's a big mindshift i actually think
i'm going through it
at a reasonable pace you know but uh
yeah
actually interesting awakening
yeah about three-part question
the first part is what are your sales
secondly who are your primary sources
for those sales and thirdly
what market share do you hold now versus
what you hope to hold someday in the
future as terms of how they're going to
grow
okay well i'll be perfectly frank we're
the whole market doesn't really exist
yet practically
there are a couple of us startups in the
game
most of the sales most of the projects
are at poc stage proof of concept we get
paid for those you know people are
trying out like dev and test deploy
environments internally
i have no idea what our market share is
we have
two real paying customers and a bunch of
other that we have actual contracts with
long term and a bunch of pocs in the
works
um we're getting these from
some service providers in japan so
existing cloud service providers are
providing this virtualized compute
environment that want to upgrade their
infrastructure and they're looking at
this type of
product
um
private clouds being built in some other
companies and telcos that's that's one
of the other uh big areas right now
and they are all the telcos so far that
we work with are at the poc stage
so do you actually have revenue yes we
have can you reveal what that is
uh it's
we we've had millions of dollars of
revenue you know but uh i can't say that
it's really steady enough to call it
like you know
sustainable
so far
but it's like i said the whole industry
right now is there's a lot of paid proof
of concept work
yep
please
yeah i just wanted to give a couple
comments from more of a piece employee
at a startup's perspective and maybe i
might have been a bit spoiled by first
working in silicon valley as an engineer
to start up before spending time in
japan and this comes from more
2007-2010 time periods so things might
have changed a little bit
but personally when i talked to a little
bit i think
richard knows who you are and and wanted
you to tell us but give them just a
brief yes i took richard's class a long
time ago stanford cs uh lived in tokyo
for about eight years and then came back
to the bay area about a few years ago
and now of my com our company is
sponsoring um this seminar and so now
i'm helping them find uh you know
partners in silicon valley okay but at
the end of my time in japan i spent a
few years kind of looking for other
alternatives maybe thinking about
working for a startup in japan and i had
some
interesting experiences comparing it to
startups uh you know here in the valley
you know you know first of all the
pay for engineers in japan tends to be
you know very low the stock it's hard to
get stock just do the laws being
different you know the chances of your
stock options being worth something are
also you know i found a bit lower and
then in some cases too i met one company
for instance that was maybe about i
guess 20 people or so and they're more
ad internet they were making an ad
server and when i started asking them
the same types of kind of due diligence
questions that that employees would ask
a venture here like oh who are your
investors you know how much money did
you get you know what are your likes
they actually took it personally they're
like no you're just a lowly employee we
don't reveal that to you you're not an
investor the guy actually got really
worked up about it and was like
how dare you ask us these sensitive
questions kind of thing and just kind of
like i was like why would i put up with
all this i might as well just go back to
the valley and work for a startup there
rather than put up with all these things
i was running into i don't want to sound
too pessimistic but just kind of at that
point it seemed like it was like you
know maybe we're just spoiled in silicon
valley but it seemed a
bit hard so that was one of the reasons
kind of why i decided well i'm going to
move back to the us for a while in my
case but i might just just been the
companies i was talking to
so i mean
you i mean you as in you you all are
very spoiled in silicon valley and
certain
certainly in terms of pay i mean it's
outrageous it's outrageous right like
the
the inflation in here there's like a
local inflation going on you know which
is crazy absolutely engineer salaries in
japan are not not the same as here uh
they're probably like uh i don't know
half to two-thirds let's say but that's
actually a very reasonable amount of
money to live in in tokyo uh
which is by the way not the world's most
expensive city
you know everybody thinks that but it's
actually more more reasonable than san
francisco by a long shot
um
and in terms of i think some of the
other points that you addressed uh that
you made are are really good you know
for instance the
the very big different gap between
management and employees
sure alan can talk about that much more
than me which we don't have by the way
in our company at all uh stock options
you know we did
uh
exactly silicon valley style stock
options
which
you can't do exactly in the japanese
system um
but
i think so by the way actually our
company we incorporated outside of japan
one of the reasons was for that
so we have flexibility on the stock
options actually the only thing that
really sucks about the japanese stock
options is that
uh you can't set the vesting term it's
like two years fixed
right oh you can do it you can use it
what you what what i've what you can't
do which is kind of annoying is you
can't create a pool that exists forever
until it's used up right right right you
have to you have to authorize each year
at the shareholders meeting
a fresh set of options to be used in
that year
so it's it's structural it's
structurally a nuisance you you work
around it but you you can do you can do
any of the best things and some other
stuff i mean mostly it's it i think it
can be done
it's just that but i think i think your
your characterization
is probably more typical of a typical
japanese startup and
we were when charlottesville was trying
to get some more more of this aggressive
use of stock options and kind of silicon
valley thing i'm not sure that we were
trying to push for higher salaries uh
because there certainly is not the
the basically the salaries are supported
by this excess of venture capital that
exists
and is managed out of the valley and
there's a tendency to want to invest it
locally so you have this this kind of
weird
venture capital bubble that exists here
but i think i think your experience is
quite typical of
the way described of the culture in a
startup in silicon valley and so it was
listening to it made me
want to ask the question so
it can be done differently it's very
rare to find a company like mediocre
that does it as differently from the
santa practice in japan as they do
but um
given you know you had your personal
connections to japan
why why what are some of the reasons
that you're choosing to forego maybe the
immediate financial rewards of
working you've probably been making more
money working in a startup in silicon
valley you are running one in japan
so what what what's sort of the the
personal thing that
that makes someone like you or i choose
to work in japan do you think versus
the the financial draw of coming back in
the valley what are the the trade-offs
that are making you stay in tokyo and do
this there i strongly prefer living
there you know personally frankly
speaking you know that's that's one
that's one aspect
i don't like driving you know so that
kind of rules out all of the valley but
um
no i mean it's uh i think it's perfectly
possible to succeed you know and uh
initially
you know
to be honest like when we met before you
know we're at a much earlier stage and i
was just kind of having fun with it now
i'm feeling extremely responsible to
continue it and make it succeed you know
and
that's what it is you know we're gonna
we're gonna do it
i don't think it matters you know where
the bulk of our uh our engineering team
is or or such yeah
i'm gonna i'm gonna end with i think
we're supposed to wrap up at five
thinking with one last question sort of
uh
york your vision
your definition of successfully what for
yourself personally and for the company
how would you
how are you characterizing success today
or the kind of the end the endgame the
end goal for what you're trying to
accomplish here well i think
very simply to build and deliver a
product that the customers will use and
and gain a lot of value from whether i'm
not going to talk about you know the
financial success of you know
revenue or ipo or getting acquired or
such you know those are all possible
options but at the end it's all about
building something that and delivering
something that is useful
that is my definition of success
and they
then you will be able to achieve it
yes absolutely
um
thank you there were
a couple of uh themes that i picked up
along the way
that
rang true to my own experience and i
would imagine to many of yours and that
is
we generally
tend to
end up being the most successful and
engaged and effective
in places that draw on our natural
talents and our natural
network of relationships
and
some of the
worst startups that i've seen were the
best business plans
someone sitting there my favorite store
was there was a
a guy who was a man
of male product manager in microsoft in
seattle who had visited japan on
business trips a few times who came to
me in the peak of the united bubble with
a proposal for
a women's portal a japanese women's
portal
and had
absolutely no connection to anything
except that the analysis on this being a
supremely attractive market segment
globally was so the plan was exquisite
the fit between that plan and him as the
person executed there was absolutely no
connection
uh and not surprisingly the business
never actually got started so i think
the one one thing i heard a couple of
times from dan is
he's in japan because
that's where his network is and that's
where he likes to be
and then the last comment on
in the end success whether as an
entrepreneur as a an employee working in
a firm of any size
in whatever industry we're in
that at the end of the day you're doing
something
creating something that's valuable for
your peers for
your colleagues for
customers for the world at large that
that's what ultimately is what it's all
about and
if you can do that whatever
methods or approaches
or teams that you bring together to do
that
ultimately
that's the goal that i think we're all
we're all shooting for and so it was it
was good to be able to reconfirm that i
invested in it in a company run by a
very well grounded
uh ceo who is who is going through that
that very challenging reason right now
from being an engineer and a very good
manager of engineers and a very good
architect and
technology strategist to
growing into
the much broader role of the ceo
it's been a really fun couple of years
so watching
dan and the company
get off the ground and i'm looking
forward to
seeing how this whole landscape plays
out and i really really do expect them
to be one of
the
first companies started in japan
in a hardcore technology to really
become a viable credible
competitor international so
it's a company to watch
thank you all for coming today
you